the jurgen experience i only desire
the approval of a relatively small
number of people
who i respect and
if they said to me i think you're
totally wrong on this douglas and i'd
listen
but when it's people who don't want to
do me to do well
for instance then of course i don't
listen to them and
and i think that's the same as it is in
all of our lives you know this i mean
you know if your wife says to you you
know you're really onto the wrong thing
here
then you know then you listen because
you know she wants you to do well
if some guy in the street with an i hate
joe rogan t-shirt on tells you what you
should do
obviously you're not going to listen to
them they don't want you to do well
and it's it's it's it's one of the tools
we all have to
to hone in our lives i suppose to work
out who wants us to do well
who wishes us well and to listen to them
even if they're critical of us and they
will be at times
and to separate out those people from
people you just
of course they don't want you to do well
you know hate you hate everything about
you and whatever
but but i'm just you know i i don't have
much uh
sympathy for the people who bang on
about being you know cancelled i mean i
do when it's people who have
you know ordinary jobs and they've just
been horribly treated by the madness of
this era
i have every sympathy for them and a lot
of the cases i write about in madness of
crowds
tries to highlight that but i don't have
much sympathy with public figures who
say
i can't say what i think and i can't
speak
up and all this sort of thing can i just
think if you're not going to now
when are you going to if you're not
going to in this life what life are you
expecting to
come where you'll do it yeah and so
i know i i am i i'm i'm comfortable
as comfortable as you can be in the end
times obviously
uh uh as everything's burning down and
there's plagues of locusts coming our
way
um i'm you know i i i honestly urge
other people to do the same
i am it's it's it's it's it's i can't
say it's dandy but it's um
it's it's a pretty good life i mean i
you know i i
and i have the satisfaction of knowing
that i'm not lying
and for young people watching in
particular this is just one of the most
important
things because as i say somewhere in
madison
the the problem with being told the
problem with going along
with being told to bend the knee raise
the fist
jump through the hoop is that it
demoralizes you
and it makes you a smaller person
inside you you you will be
demoralized because you'll know that you
shouldn't have done that and at some
level you will
think badly of yourself for having done
it you'll feel regretful
you'll feel cowardly and it will affect
your life in other ways
and the opposite is also true
the person who doesn't stand with the
mob the person who doesn't go along with
the mob the person who refuses to walk
with the crowd
will feel quietly but significantly
better about themselves and i think will
be a better person
and they will achieve more in their
lives whatever that is
because they will have self-respect and
that's what these that's what
totalitarian movements across
history always knew was if you grind
people down and make them agree to lies
because you will then be able to make
and do anything you know there's this if
i say
there's this very very telling thing
that happened in the communist era in
eastern europe
vaslav havel great late czech leader
says this when he was
one of the great czech dissidents and
playwrights of the period in the 60s and
70s
he wrote a piece once which which is
really worth reading again today
where he he he cites the example of a
green grosser in prague
who has to put up in his window like
everyone else
the notice that says workers of the
world unite
and it's sent by party headquarters to
all green grocers and you all have to
hang it
and vaclav harvald says a number of
things happen from this
the first thing is that of course that
the green grocer is showing to everyone
that he is a party lawyer and he
wouldn't be able to operate as a
business if he didn't do this thing
but it also hangs there every day as a
sign of his subjugation
it's a little thing but it hangs there
as a sign of his subjugation
and it reminds him that he's not the man
he could be
now one of the one of the one of the
results of that
is that such a person ends up hating the
people who make him hang the sign
hates him because they have demoralized
him
but havel's point among others is you
think you're doing a little
thing but you're not you are diminishing
your soul by doing this because you
know that you could be something more
than the person who just has to hang
whatever party headquarters tells you to
hang this week
well said thank you absolutely
outstanding
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go download spotify
much love bubba